the premise seems totally absurd when
you read it the all-powerful superman
teaming with cowardly and perpetually
hungry teenager shaggy to throw down
against a shape-shifting dog jake and a
face stealing assassin arya stark this
is real however and it's multiverses the
upcoming warner brothers platform
fighter and the latest game to challenge
smash bros for its platform fighter
throne
we got an early look at the upcoming
close alpha test and so far multiverses
is not only a viable challenger to
nintendo's all-star smasher but it could
be a glimpse at the future of fighting
games in general
on the surface multiverses looks very
similar to other platform fighting games
as the combatants zip around a stage
with multiple ledges throwing out
attacks and trying to knock each other
off of the screen the names on the
marquee may be different superman wonder
woman and batman from dc comics bugs
bunny and taz from looney tunes shaggy
from scooby-doo etc but the action at a
glance stays with the tried and true
smash brothers formula it's not entirely
the same however and nowhere is that
more apparent than in 2v2 team battles
teams are split into red and blue teams
and the first team to score four
knockouts wins this is a slightly
different approach to the stock battles
of smash bros as knockouts act as a
scored point rather than one player
losing a life this scoring format allows
both players to stay in the match the
entire time rather than one remaining
player being at a disadvantage even with
this change in scoring the team battle
mode sounds similar to other games that
offer it but there's a deeper level of
strategy to consider here that sets
multiverses apart elevating it from
potential smash bros clone to a game
that can stand on its own two feet every
character has at least one move in their
arsenal that not only damages the enemy
but gives a slight benefit to a teammate
as well when shaggy charges up to full
power with his neutral special for
example his teammate also receives a
power boost wonder woman's down special
attack gives her a shield but it also
increases a teammate's defense if they
get close to one another while it's
active a few characters have a tether
ability that can latch onto a teammate
making both fighters more difficult to
launch off-screen the combinations and
character synergies to discover are
plentiful even here in a closed alpha
test with only 15 characters i am
excited to see how deep this system goes
once the full version releases there are
single player modes to check out but
they're much more by the numbers than
the team battles 1v1 is the best way to
truly test your skills competitively as
it's a straightforward first to two
points battle with no teammates to worry
about stages do have some obstacles like
the platforms that retract in the
haunted mansion and some tree fort
buildings that can be destroyed but
nothing in the alpha test stages was as
wild as say smash brothers pokey floats
the four player free-for-all meanwhile
is tailor-made for parties or less
competitive environments with frenzied
action happening all over the screen
while they offer plenty of fun
neither of these modes offer a new twist
on old gameplay like team battles do so
they don't stand out quite as much
all three of these formats benefit
tremendously from the game's rollback
netcode which provided a smooth online
experience in nearly every match we've
played there were a few instances where
characters would glitch out or randomly
teleport from one place to another but
in the 50 matches i played i can count
only two instances of those technical
issues every other match felt like my
opponents were sitting in the same room
which is impressive especially in
matches with four players granted this
was an early preview of the closed alpha
test so the number of players logged on
likely wasn't massive but it's still as
good of a sign as we could hope for at
this point while the fighting isn't
revolutionary the free-to-play format is
what could give multiverses an edge
fighting games fit incredibly well into
an f2p model and multiverses is solid
proof the game offers multiple
progression systems a standard battle
pass with free and premium options a
profile based leveling system and
character specific progression each one
offers separate rewards the character
specific rewards include different
cosmetics and perks that can be equipped
to enhance abilities the career
progression provides in-game currency to
purchase new characters and skins from
the in-game shop and the battle pass
offers general cosmetics like banners
and costumes taunts and other perks for
the entire roster earning rewards is
remarkably quick too as i never felt
like i was grinding for more gold or
battle pass points seasonal milestones
and daily missions make the 50 level
battle pass seem to fly by with one 1
000 point seasonal milestone earning
multiple levels at once the character
progression isn't quite as fast but
earning an xp boost through the battle
pass can temporarily fix that career
progression is also slower but as the
rewards earned there aren't as impactful
as the battle pass or character perks i
didn't really mind the ways multiverses
let you customize the experience through
earned cosmetics also speak to how well
a battle pass fits into a fighting game
like this one of the types of cosmetics
you can earn are knockout animations
that play every time you score a
successful knockout examples include
dark sides omega beams the space kook
from scooby-doo and banners for houses
lannister stark and targaryen but for my
money the best one is that's all folks
we're the iconic looney tunes ending
screen porky pig included shows up
wherever your opponent was eliminated it
made me laugh every single time giving
the game an extra layer of personality
on top of all the action that
personality is bolstered by the game's
voice acting which is one of the best
parts of the game bet you didn't know
about my dancing powers my roommate
thinks i have anger issues let's see
what you think get ready to eat my sword
each character is fully voiced most of
them by the original voice actors maisie
williams voices arya stark matthew
lillard provides the voice of shaggy and
kevin conroy tara strong and george
newburn portray batman harley quinn and
superman respectively each character is
given authenticity through their voices
throwing out quick one-liners during
battle that will make you chuckle
knocking out tom and jerry is an
absolute joy for example as tom belts
out his iconic scream whenever defeated
it's not just in battle either as
eventually you can unlock announcer
voice packs for many of the characters
through the character specific
progression as well more importantly
some of the spoken dialogue is specific
to certain situations providing an extra
layer of depth that shows just how much
effort player first games is putting
into this project for example during one
battle i played as arya stark and teamed
with shaggy versus adventure times jake
the dog and superman as the battle
begins jake exclaims i can't believe i'm
paired up with superman after we won the
match are you quipped go back to your
master dog at the victory screen
referring to the fallen jake nickelodeon
all-star brawl another smash inspired
game garnered a lot of criticism for its
lack of voices and that omission seems
even more egregious in retrospect after
seeing how much it adds to the
experience here in multiverses while
this is a closed alpha test and a lot
can change between now and when the game
officially launches multiverse is
shaping up to be a special game the
roster of characters is wacky and
wonderful the action is both familiar
and fresh and the free-to-play
progression systems let you earn rewards
while never feeling like a grind there
are even a few hints of the future in
the alpha like how the tutorial uses me
seeks from rick and morty as targets or
how wonder woman says get over here when
she pulls an opponent toward her with
the lasso of truth no matter what
surprises are coming to multiverses next
based on this closed alpha test that
future looks as bright as shaggy at 100
of his power multiverses will launch on
xbox series x and s xbox one playstation
4 playstation 5 and pc the closed alpha
test runs may 19 to 27 and an open beta
has been announced for july and for more
multiverses news and more stay locked in
to gamespot